[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
hoy con un espacio deportivo vamos a
hablar de ciclismo con el periodista y
escritor william quien nos acompaña
desde nuestros estudios en parís
bienvenido koubbi buenos días voy a
estar presentando su libro egan bernal y
los hijos de la cordillera viaje al país
de los escarabajos es un recorrido por
el ciclismo colombiano que empieza por
los años 50 desde el zipa forero y
cochise en rodríguez pasando por
santiago botero y mauricio soler hasta
llegar a nairo quintana y como no llegan
en bernal we es este libro un homenaje
al ciclismo colombiano
y lo escribí primero se lo merecen y eso
va estuviese vivo en forma de novelas y
como un viaje al país de los escarabajos
economía es un país muy desconocido y
con forma de violencia y los escarabajos
que no hay gentes nobles viajeros que no
hay gente más buena como dice la canción
supieron dar una imagen mucho más
positiva
y gran parte de este libro está dedicado
a iván bernal a quien hemos vuelto a ver
en todo su esplendor en esta edición del
giro de italia que está transcurriendo
cree usted que el gam bernal va a dejar
una huella en el ciclismo mundial
si estoy convencido
que tenemos en invernal una barcaza
dejada para entrar en la leyenda del
ciclismo como los más grandes un tour de
fans a los 22 años un día bueno casi a
los 24 a pesar de la competencia se está
abriendo una autopista
yo diría incluso que llegan tienen
capacidades datos físicos espectaculares
e inteligencia en carrera datos que más
superiores a los que tenía miguel
indurain por ejemplo o iphone e
intereses en carrera porque pues por su
colocación por su adaptación por sus
fuerzas de cooperación en la tercera
semana de un gran tour
tiene todo eso
poder para ganar mucho más vueltas
muchos otros grandes tours queda una
incógnita su dolor en la espalda de
momento parece que la estaba superando
sobre los años 80 y la explosión de
figuras como lucho herrera o fabio parra
usted cuenta en el libro que esa
presencia de los esperaba escarabajos
terminó siendo un salvavidas para el
tour de francia qué importancia tuvieron
los colombianos en esos años
efectivamente la llegada de los
colombianos en el túnel hablamos de los
de los años 80 y
fue espectacular
por su manera de ir al ataque diagonal
tuvo un aliento nuevo aire de cordillera
porque tú de verdad y ha perdido su
encanto
y se había abogado
y distribuían los premios por antelación
y de verdad todos estábamos aburridos
la magia y las piernas de luchó fabio
pato mejilla
condorito y mastín pues dieron al tour
otra
no salgo del tour de un gamer esta wiki
se puede decir rápidamente de todos los
asientos ciclistas colombianos que usted
menciona en ese libro se queda en
particular con la historia de uno solo
de ellos
no lo siento pero no el hecho de haber
podido entrar en su en su intimidad fue
lo que más me impactó pero si me permite
si puedo quedarme con 3
en juegos muy emotivos muy emocionantes
diría que primero hay
era el jugado de mauricio soler pues
campeón destrozado después de su caída
en la vuelta a suiza me quedo con la
historia de coches que es un verdadero
monumento hablando y andando
y también con
el destino de patrocino jiménez
grandísimos nombres esos es sin duda
alguna de las historias y que no
colombiano muchísimas gracias por
habernos acompañado este tiempo y
gracias también a ustedes por habernos
acompañado que decir porque más mucho
más siempre es 24 y 324 puntocom
[Música]